[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs toutes vos idées sorties
culturelles ou ludiques dans le
département merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro tout de suite
le sommaire on parlera théâtre et
surtout comédie avec notre invité au
fémur est présidente du festival de
théâtre mort de rire sera avec nous pour
nous dévoiler le programme de la 4e
édition à saint cyr l'école le centre de
musique baroque de versailles et le
concert spirituel fêtent leurs 30 ans
avec une oeuvre inédite un opéra créé à
partir de pièces déjà existante de
compositeurs connus au plus rares nous
avons assisté à la dernière répétition
enfin dans notre rendez-vous junior
mélanie poquet nous emmènera pour un
voyage à l'autre bout du monde et même
encore plus loin
nous partirons à la découverte de la
culture japonaise et dans l'espace pour
deux événements ce week end de la
couleur des sculptures mobiles et des
peintures interactive l'univers de daix
exposé au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au 20
octobre
parmi les installations de toiles en
réalité augmentée à l'aide d'une
application une nouvelle oeuvre se
dévoile entre les mains du spectateur et
chacun est libre d'y voir ce qu'il
souhaite c'est de l'art abstrait donc ça
représente ce qu'on veut bien y voit
donc l'état peinture donc la peinture on
est dans l'abstraction lyrique
beaucoup de couleurs parce qu'il ya
d'abord un travail de croo mis dans ma
peinture comme dans les installations
j'ai un travail autour de l'équilibré
j'ai essayé de trouver un point
d'équilibré pour
pour qu'il y ait une construction en
fait ce travail avec le vide et je viens
construire autour du vide un demi siècle
pour mort pas là comme une fête cette
année ses 50 ans pour l'occasion
l'association nord pas d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui propose une exposition
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 22 octobre
à l'espace albert camus de maurepas et
on peut voir que la ville s'est
construite très rapidement écouter avant
c'était une ferme en fait donc le fermi
allait cesser ses fesses et estaires et
donc au repas s'est construit en fait
sur les terres agricoles de l'ap qu'on
appelle le plein de la sljo et puis au
fur et à mesure les quartiers se sont
construit donc on a commencé par la
prévent dry la malle me donne les
baissière tous les quartiers ne mord pas
se sont développées très vite en cinq
six ans et après on a bien sûr ça a
continué avec les promenades au fur et à
mesure des années quoi
[Musique]
de la pièce de boulevard à la comédie
absurde le théâtre sous toutes ses
formes à saint-cyr-l'ecole le festival
mort de rire revient pour une quatrième
édition du 20 au 22 octobre est avec
nous cette présidente
ophélie murray bonjour bonjour alors
pendant ces trois jours vous allez
accueillir quatre troupes quatre
spectacles tout public seront présentés
au théâtre gérard philipe
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
plus oui donc on a quatre troupes qui
viennent d'un peu partout la première
troupe c'est la compagnie roxane qui
vient de franconville qui vont nous
présenter un doigt de madère donc un
ensemble de pièces de courteline voilà
et il y deux bassons également le samedi
donc on aura le cossart d'aurillac qui
viendra jouer j'ai un petit doute
on ne choisit pas sa famille de jean
christophe bach dont classés voilà une
comédie un peu absurde sur un mariage
voilà donc avec plein de couleurs qui se
passe dans une école
voilà le soir on aura une création
de la compagnie qui à gif sur yvette qui
s'appelle les affranchis et la pièce ces
micmacs story bas c'est assez sympa
c'est pendant la prohibition est en fait
ces deux familles qui vont se rencontrer
mais qui n'ont rien à voir l'une avec
l'autre et ça va être un peu le clash
entre ces deux familles et le dimanche
on retrouvera la commedia de la blies
pour une pièce qui s'appelle j'adore
l'amour j'aimerais bien le refaire là
par jour et voilà là c'est du vrai
théâtre de vaudeville avec l'ex mari qui
débarque
voilà la bonne situation qu'ils vivent
le complice a donc des pièces
essentiellement comique pourquoi avoir
voulu axer ce festival sur la comédie
c'était un peu pour retrouver un nouveau
public le théâtre souvent les gens
l'imaginent avec le molière le classique
le théâtre classique et nous on voulait
un peu coupé les préjugés en fait et
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est axée sur la
comédie et voilà le but c'était de faire
rire le festival mort de rire qu'a lieu
au moment de la toussaint
voilà c'était un peu pour faire le jeu
de mots et puis réconciliés les
spectateurs avec le théâtre un petit
clin d'oeil aussi justement la fête de
la toussaint et on précise que ce sont
des troupes amateurs et vous l'avez dit
certains viennent même de loin aurillac
pour la compagnie
cossart comment avez vous choisi chaque
chaque spectacle chaque troupe
c'est un appel à candidatures en fait un
prêt on reçoit pas mal de demandes avec
des vidéos parfois des invités à les
voir directement les spectacles et puis
d'après faut faire son choix c'est pas
toujours facile
et voilà parce qu'ils sont pas là cette
année on espère les avoir l'année
prochaine pourquoi pas un petit
roulement quand même oui bah oui faut
essayer satisfaire tout le monde
le but de de nos comédiens amateurs
c'est de pouvoir jouer un maximum est de
se faire connaître
un mot sur les modalités parce qu'il ya
différents types de billets pour ceux
qui veulent assister à l'ensemble du
festival ou ceux qui ne peuvent assister
qu'à une soldate
oui donc l'idéal c'est quand même le
pass festival qui est valable tout le
week end donc 25 euros pour les adultes
et
15 euros pour les enfants et sinon il ya
les billets à l'unité voilà à 8 et 4
euros respectivement
et on a la possibilité aussi gagner des
places sur l'antisèche voilà donc à
aller sur le site internet du coup le
top départ du festival est donné le
vendredi 20 octobre à 19h30 avec un
cocktail la représentation de la pièce
un doigt de madère à 20h30
il se termine dimanche avec vous l'avez
dit j'adore l'amour j'aimerais bien de
refaire un jour mais il est aussi une
remise de prix ce jour là car le public
est invité à participer leurs de quelle
manière
oui bat sur chaque pièce on demande aux
spectateurs de voter donc ils donnent
une note entre 1 et 5 5 étant la
meilleure note
et puis après on fait les comptes pour
voir qui c'est qu'a récolté le meilleur
score
donc le prix du public un dernier mot
puisque sa quatrième édition c'est
devenu un rendez vous un petit peu
incontournable c'est l'occasion de
passer un bon moment en famille surtout
avec les vacances qui approchent
oui tout à fait c'est que des pièces
tout public donc ça permet vraiment à
tout le monde de venir une sortie pas
trop cher qui plairont je pense aux
enfants et aux parents petit comme en
grand en tout cas merci beaucoup fait
dit murray d'être venu sur notre plateau
pour nous parler du festival mort de
rire avant le rappel ça commence ce
vendredi 20 octobre à saint cyr l'école
et des informations prendre vos places
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
beaucoup ophélie murray merci à vous une
création inédite à partir d'extraits
d'opéras connus ou non c'est l'opéra
imaginaire du centre de musique baroque
de versailles et de jules concert
spirituel une oeuvre anniversaire pour
célébrer les 30 ans des deux structures
nous avons suivi la dernière répétition
avant les premières représentations de
ce week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rameau lully ou montéclair différents
compositeurs réunis ensemble dans une
même oeuvre un opéra imaginaire créé à
partir de pièces inédites des xviie et
xviiie siècles
on a été chercher les off on avait joué
depuis 30 ans je pense qu'on avait
préféré
et puis d'autres choses qu'on avait dans
nos armoires et qu'on ne jouera jamais
donc c'est une occasion unique
d'entendre je pense que ce serait
probablement la première et dernière
fois qu'on entendra des hommes de stuc
de bertin de la douille de colas nous
blâmons sont des vrais shader on a fait
la propre histoire propre opérant comme
avait fait louis xiv avec le ballet ou
avec la comédie une création originale
qui reprend les codes d'un opéra
traditionnel trois solistes interprètent
les personnages habituels
une reine et perdu d'un jeune homme lui
même amoureux d'une princesse des rôles
qui aide à créer une continuité entre
les différents auteurs
[Musique]
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on est
quand même sur plus de 50 ans de musique
donc on sent que l'écriture change un
peu le lit et ramos est absolument pas
la même chose donc ses dents ça comment
comment réunir sa essai c'est un des
films je trouve ça un défi très
intéressant
un défi pour célébrer les 30 ans du
centre de musique baroque de versailles
et du centre spirituel
les 70 artistes se produiront à
bruxelles paris et metz jusqu'au 15
octobre
dernière étape le 18 à l'opéra royal du
château de versailles
oui
[Musique]
cette semaine pour notre rendez-vous
juniors on vous propose de voyager loin
et même très loin de la france mélanie
veut nous emmener où nous emmène au pays
du soleil levant parce que ce samedi
vous pouvez partir à la découverte du
japon le canada reiki d'eau club de
guyancourt propose plusieurs activités
ce stage un nom bien particulier comme
je ne parle pas le japonais je laisse
jean marc giffard ou le présenter midi
gare et donc c'est évidemment ces
japonais ça veut dire l'art de
contempler les feuilles rouges de
l'érable donc ce moment c'est de saison
c'est une journée culturelle qui permet
de voir un petit peu les différentes
facettes de la culture japonaise et il y
aura des arts martiaux de l'aïkido du
tianhe d'eau et même des juges du canada
m'a alors ça une sorte de bilboquet vous
pourrez aussi découvrir de la
calligraphie et de l'origami
c'est à vivre dès l'âge de 7 ans à la
villa jean monnet de guyancourt
attention les inscriptions sont
obligatoires et le deuxième voyage c'est
encore plus loin que le japon
alors thomas pesquet les spationautes
français rêvent un jour de partir sur
mars
quelqu'un l'a devancé un robot connu
sous le nom de curiosity en 2020 il va
être rejoint par un autre rover une
maquette de sauveur et textes
actuellement exposé à l'observatoire
versailles saint quentin à guyancourt là
aussi l'euro verte permettra de savoir
si sur mars il ya eu de la vie nous
sommes bricon l'instrument qui se trouve
en haut du mât qui s'appelle super
calmes
donc c'est un instrument qui permet de
faire de la spectrométrie laser donc il
ya un laser qui va tirer sur les roches
pour voilà ont déterminé en fait la
structure et la composition
mais il n'ya pas que le rover donc ce
qu'en fait il ya une quinzaine
d'activités qui sont proposés le samedi
14 octobre pour les 6 12 ans écoutait
des lâchers de ballons le superbe euro
vers que vous avez derrière vous
qu'est-ce que virtuelle qui nous permet
de voyager de voyager sur mass
le public va pouvoir découvrir les
missions principales de nos trois
laboratoires laboratoire spatial
environnement changement climatique et
arctique
alors pour ce qui est du
10 pensez à vous inscrire le dimanche là
c'est en entrée libre
camille j'aimerais terminer par une
citation de la haute saône en sage
chinois
un voyage de milieux commence toujours
par un premier pas alors japon mars
jolie citation en tout cas l'un ou
l'autre de toute façon c'est le
dépaysement assuré merci beaucoup mais
là ni pour ses idées sorties on passe
maintenant à notre agenda 15e édition du
salon international de l'art
contemporain armanet peintres sculpteurs
et photographes une soixantaine
d'artistes sont à découvrir
une tombola sera aussi organisé les
fonds récoltés serviront à financer la
recherche maladie ou le handicap et si
vous êtes amoureux des produits du
terroir rendez vous à paris à bercy
village pour la première édition de
destination parc et 51 parcs naturels
régionaux font découvrir leurs richesses
siro fromage ou miel jus de poire même
la haute vallée de chevreuse a posé ses
valises et ses produits jusqu'à dimanche
on écoute parce qu'elle camus au micro
de michael ni d'euros on est en relation
directe avec eux sachant qu'on travaille
à peu près tout année avec eux et sur
certains des événements des seuils de
valoriser leurs produits de proposer aux
gens du jus de pommes etc afin qu'ils se
fassent connaître
donc ceci fait un petit peu
naturellement on fait par rapport aux
liens qu'on a longtemps avec eux et
enfin ce samedi 14 octobre pour les
journées nationales de l'architecturé de
nombreux événements sont proposés dans
toute l'île de france
l'occasion de découvrir des lieux
d'exception comme l'école nationale
supérieure d'architecturé de versailles
qui ouvre ses portes au public le 7 8
loisirs est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis nous espérons que vous
avez fait le plein d'idées sorties pour
le week end et pour la semaine n'oubliez
pas de retrouver votre émission sur
notre site internet tv 70 points comme
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]